hey everyone it's nurse Sarah with
registered nurse rn.com and in this
video I'm going to demonstrate how to
insert an indwelling Foley catheter on a
female patient so let's get started
before you insert an indwelling catheter
you want to make sure that you have a
doctor's order then you want to make
sure you confirm everything so you want
to do those rights for instance do you
have the right patient and are we doing
the right procedure did The Physician
order an indwelling catheter or did The
Physician order an in and out catheter
you want to definitely confirm that you
also want to make sure you have the
right supplies and your facility will
have different supplies so here we have
a kit I've read everything that my kit
includes which is everything I need to
do the procedure but you want to make
sure you're familiar with what's in your
kit and what you have available to you
and then another important step you want
to take is you want to assess your
patients allergies there's two big
things you want to be looking for you
want to make sure your patient's not
allergic to latex because some of these
catheters are made out of latex and you
want to make sure that your page is not
allergic to iodine because the cleaning
solution we're going to be using to
clean the labia before we actually
insert contains Betadine which is a type
of iodine so you'd want to use a
different type of cleaner per your
facilities protocol then after we have
confirmed everything we want to go to
our patient and we want to explain what
the doctor has ordered and what we're
going to be doing we want to go into
detail about it so this patient knows
exactly what to expect answer all your
patients questions and then get their
consent for this procedure so we've
explained the procedure to our patient
the patient is agreeable now it's time
for me to gather my supplies and perform
hand hygiene so let me touch on supplies
for a minute I talked about getting your
kit so again read what's in the kit so
you know exactly what you need this kit
right here has everything I need but a
lot of kids like I've worked with in the
past they don't have the pericare
supplies because you want to provide
Perry care before you actually insert
the Foley so you'll need to get some
washcloths so everything for that then
and you want to grab some other things
like extra pair of sterile gloves in
case yours break or they don't fit
because that does happen and you'll need
some clean gloves as well any PPE that
you may need if your patient has some
type of contact precautions or something
else you're going to need some alcohol
prep this is used to secure the stat
lock securement device and if that's
what you're going to be using and you're
going to need someone else to help you
this could be a nursing assistant but
some facilities are now requiring that
this is done as a two-person catheter
insertion technique now what we're going
to do is we are going to position the
patient so there's two positions you can
use for the female it really depends on
the patient's Mobility the first one is
called the dorsal recombinant position
and this is where you lay the patient
back with the legs flexed and apart
exposing the genital area or if your
patient has mobility issues or joint
issues they're not really good at moving
around a better choice is the Sims
position and then after positioning them
put a waterproof pad under the patient
this is going to help protect that linen
and help you have easy cleanup and you
want to cover the patient to make them
feel comfortable and less exposed but be
careful that you keep that sheet out of
the way so it's not going to contaminate
your sterile field it's now time to open
up our Foley kit particularly that clear
plastic part so we're just going to
bring It Up Lift these sides up and then
pull the tray out and then put this back
to the side so I'm going to take this
off and then look at what's in our kit
here we have cleanser to cleanse the
periurethral area first we will do this
first before we do anything else and
then it has directions to use some other
little education pieces in a different
language Spanish and then these are
stickers that we're going to be putting
in the chart and on our drainage tubing
we'll put that to the side so let's prep
for this so I've washed my hands and
I've done clean gloves so I'm going to
take this out in here
and in this little package we have the
soap towelettes to clean the area and
then afterwards we have this to wash our
hands with so when you go to perform
Perry care this is a great time to get a
good visualization of the anatomy of the
patient and where the location of the
urethral meatus is this is the opening
to the bladder and that's where we're
wanting to go and what we're going to do
is you want to tell the patient before
you even touch them in this area that
you're going to touch the labia and that
you're going to spread them so we've
said that and you're going to take your
non-dominant hand you want to be on the
side of your patient where your
non-dominant hand is going to be towards
the patient so I'm right-handed so this
is my left hand and you're going to take
your index finger and thumb and you're
just going to spread the labia out and
in the female there's three openings you
have a top opening which is the urethral
meatus that's where we're going we're
going for that top opening you have a
bottom opening that that is the vaginal
opening and then you have a third
opening which is the anus so how can you
find this urethral meatus well use some
landmarks on the female we have two
labia we have the labia majora which are
the larger outer folds this usually in
most women has pubic hair on it and then
we have the labia minora these right
here and these are the smaller folds and
then where these smaller folds meet
together as you can see right here where
they come together that is known as the
frenulum and about a few centimeters
below the frenulum is going to be the
urethral meatus now let's say you're
having trouble finding that top opening
their urethral meatus well one thing you
could do is you could have the patient
bear down or try to act like they're
urinating and that sometimes will relax
that urethral meatus and it'll make it
more prominent it really depends on the
anatomy of the female sometimes they're
a little hard to find and you really
have to work at finding it so this is
where your helper comes in to help you
can get a flashlight or a pen light to
illuminate this area so you can find it
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to provide the periurethral care
before we actually insert and Perry
urethral care is a type of pericare and
what we're doing is we're cleaning
around this urethra area so we're really
concentrating on the labia minora and
that urethral meatus it came with three
towelettes for the cares so take your
non-dominant hand warn the patient
you're going to be spreading the labia
minora and here I have a mannequin the
mannequins tissue is very hard in a
normal clinical setting on a real
patient it's very easy to move the labia
around but here these labia are very
stiff but you'll get the idea and we
really need to spread these open and
we're going to take one of our
towelettes it came with three and we're
going to start with the labia minora
that's the furthest away from us we're
going to go from Top to bottom so we're
going to go from Top get up here at the
top and then go down all the way to anus
and then discard then we're going to go
to the labia closest to us from top to
bottom same way all the way to the anus
and then discard and then we're going to
take our last towelette and we're going
to go into the middle and we're really
going to concentrate getting over that
meatus because we want that to be clean
for insertion so we're going to go in
the middle and we're going to wipe from
top to bottom and discard then we're
going to Dolph our gloves and perform
hand hygiene we're going to take our
wrap kit we can touch this part right
now because this is the shiny side and
the shiny side is going to go on your
surrounding surfaces remember shiny go
in surrounding surfaces it's not sterile
so we can touch this so we're going to
move this and we're going to orient it
toward the insertion side so it's going
to go on the bed and in between the
patient's legs now we're going to open
our CSR wrap so you have to do this in a
specific way because we don't want to
reach over our kit with our hand which
could contaminate the sterile field so
what we're going to do is we're going to
peel this to open it that part off and
we are going to take this top tab off
and pull it this way away from us you
have one inch on this dull side that is
considered non-sterile so it's like a
one inch border that you could touch or
you could just grab the shiny side and
pull it's whatever you prefer pull that
then we're going to do our side tabs so
remember you have one inch roll like
that and then we're going to do the
inside one pull it like that next what
we're going to do is we're going to Dawn
the sterile gloves now you never want to
turn your back on this whole sterile
feel because if you do you're going to
have to start over once the sterile
gloves are on you can't touch anything
outside of the kit you can only touch
things that are inside the kit because
everything is sterile so we're going to
Dawn these sterile gloves outside the
sterile field so now let's open up our
gloves turning the package around down
and always read the little words on the
packaging to help you Orient it we're
going to take the tabs stick our hands
underneath the tabs and pull it out
you have about a one to two inch border
to work with so that paper folds out
nice and neat so you can get in there to
those gloves I'm going to glove my
dominant hands so I'm going to take my
non-dominant grab this cuff and I'm
going to slide it over like so hey this
is now sterile we cannot touch anything
outside of our sterile field and then
I'm going to go under this cuff right
here to glove my dominant hand hey now
we're sterile now we're going to drape
the patient and we're going to be
placing two different pads the first pad
we're going to place is called the under
pad and the reason we're placing all of
these pads is because we want to extend
our sterile field so we are going to get
the under pad it should be the top pad
and we're just going to grab it here I
want you to see both of these sides we
have a shiny side and we have a dull
side remember the shiny side is the side
that's going to go on the surrounding
surfaces so it's going to go down so
we're going to place this under the
patient's bottom and the key with this
is you got to be careful because
whenever you go to place this under the
patient's bottom you don't want to
contaminate your sterile gloves if so
you'll have to start all over so you
sort of want to grab it on this dull
side in here and then this is where your
assistant comes in handy they're going
to help the patient lift their bottom
and we're just going to place it and let
it fall and go underneath the patient
like so then we're going to take our
finished straighter drape and put it
over the patient's genital it's going to
have a hole that gives us an area to
work so we're going to grab this and let
this unfold itself and then we're going
to take the shiny side put it on the
patient and again being careful as we
drape so we're just going to put it over
the patient like this now we're going to
set up our kit and this kit is really
cool because it labels every step for us
so here we have our Foley with the
drainage bag we have the securement
device a stat lock device that we're
going to be applying later so the very
first thing that we need to do is we
need to open the add-on so we're going
to open this iodine and we are going to
put it on these swabs right here step
two is poor swap pour on the swabs so
tear here
and then we're going to just put it on
our swabs right here because this is
what's going to be used to clean our
labia and we're going to discard this
then what we're going to do is we're
going to attach the water syringe so
we're going to just connect it to this
port here we no longer test the balloon
prior to insertion because doing that
they have found changes the shape of
that balloon prior to inserting it up
through the urethra when we change the
shape it could damage the urethra which
could cause a urinary tract infection
and we don't want to do that so here's
our water syringe and this Foley that we
are dealing with it tells us it's a 14
French and to inflate with 10 mL of
water you always want to pay attention
to that because that's really important
whenever you go to remove it so this is
the port that we're going to be in
instilling that water in whenever we're
ready to after insertion but right now
we're just going to connect it there and
set it aside because we're going to be
using that when we're done inserting the
next what we're going to do is we are
going to dispense the lubricant okay
here so we can lubricate the tip of our
catheter prior to insertion this is
really important so this is a
comfortable procedure as much as it can
be for your patient so we're going to
take that we're going to just put it in
here and discard this then we are going
to remove the catheter very carefully
from this plastic sheathing you
definitely want to let it coil like that
because if you just pull this thing out
it's going to go flying off your sterile
field and then you're going to start all
over so for females we want to lubricate
at least two inches of this tip so we're
going to put it in there okay so we've
prepped everything that we need now next
up we here in a moment are going to
clean the area prior to insertion but
also in some kits you have a urine
sample collection cup if you needed that
with some labeling and then you have
your drainage bag you always want to
make sure your kit came with a drainage
bag because if not you would need that
now we're going to prep the side before
we actually insert the Foley with those
Betadine swab that we just prepped so in
order to do this we are going to take
our non-dominant hand and we're going to
warn the patient that we're going to be
spreading the labia and once this hand
goes here to spread the labia it must
stay here the whole time because it's no
longer sterile until we're done
inserting so we've told the patient and
we're going to really spread the labia
minora because that is where we're going
again this is a stiff mannequin these
labia do not spread like they would
normally so we're going to take our
first swab and we're going to go to that
labia furthest away we're going to go
from top to bottom and then we're going
to discard this
then we're going to take our next swab
and we're going to go to the labia that
is closest to us and go from top to
bottom then discard that then we're
going to take our last swab and we're
going to go in the middle so we're going
to go from top to bottom really
concentrate on that meatus and then
discard now before you actually go to
insert the Foley you want to tell the
patient to concentrate on their
breathing so tell them to slowly breathe
in and out and to Bear down because with
that breathing it's going to help relax
that urethra along with bearing down
which is what we want so the patient is
breathing in and out whenever I hear an
exhale that is when I'm going to insert
into the urethra and I'm going to go
about
two to three inches until I see urine
return
and we do have urine return in our
tubing so now that we have urine return
we're going to insert another two inches
since we are inserting on a female just
to make sure that that is nice and in
the bladder so we have done that now we
need to instill water in the bloom so
I'm going to have to take my dominant
hand to actually push on that plunger to
get that balloon inflated but this
catheter cannot be left to itself
because the bladder or the urethra could
contract the fully out we'd have to
start all over so now that we're done
inserting we are going to take this
non-dominant hand and it's going to just
hold our catheter like this while we
actually inflate our balloon so I'm
going to take my dominant hand and I'm
going to depress this plunger as I am
instilling the water in the balloon it
should be very easy patients shouldn't
be complaining of any pain or anything
like that and if they do complain of
pain you may be in the urethra so you
may have to advance the catheter a
little bit more now I I have inflated
the balloon I'm going to let go it
should stay in place and I'm just going
to just detach this and discard then
what I want to do is I want to gently
tug on this and make sure I have a
little bit of resistance because that
tells me that balloon is where it's
supposed to be it's right above that
bladder neck setting nice and firmly so
now that we have done that what we want
to do is we want to clean up the patient
and get them covered up and then we're
going to secure the device so we're just
going to take this off
and then we are going to discard all of
this per our facilities protocol we're
going to cover up our patient and we're
going to keep the thigh exposed because
that is where we're going to secure the
device so here's the actual device
itself this is going to go on the inner
thigh of the female and then there's a
skin protectant pad which is going to be
applied prior to actually putting it on
so let's put it on so the first step of
what you want to do before you place
this on the patient is that you want to
put this actual catheter in the retainer
because we don't want to put this on the
patient's skin and then clamp it shut
it's not going to feel too good to the
patient so we have the arrow see this
Arrow here it's pointing towards the
insertion site that is where we want to
go so we have the arrow pointing we're
going to take the bifurcation of the
catheter and there's this little part
right here hanging off this white part
it's going to just set in between this
catheter right here see like that it's
right there and then we're going to
close it shut by pressing these little
lines right here we're not going to
press in the middle we're going to press
those lines and it's nice and in place
now we want to find a spot to put our
stat lock so make sure the patient's leg
is completely extended and we're going
to go on the inner thigh of the female
and we want to go about right here but
we want some slack in this catheter line
we don't want too much or too little so
according to the manufacturer they say
pick your spot and then go back about an
inch and that is about where you want to
go
so you want to keep note of this because
this is the area you're going to clean
we're going to clean this whole area
with alcohol prep and then with skin
prep so I'm going to put my fingers here
just to remind me I'm taking my alcohol
prep and I'm cleaning this area I'm
going to clean an area that's even
bigger than that
stat lock device we want to remove any
dirt and grime that is on this skin and
then we're going to let that dry
completely now that that has dried
completely I'm going to take the skin
prep and I'm going to clean that whole
area again but this is just protectant
to protect the patient's skin because
these stat locks stay on the skin for a
while especially if they're going to be
having an indwelling catheter
and you want to change these stat locks
out according to your facility's
protocol it's usually about every seven
days and while you're waiting for your
site to dry you want to put your
initials in the date for when you
inserted this so the person behind you
will know when to change this out now
that it is dry we're ready to place the
stat lock on the skin so to do that we
are going to pull back one side of the
adhesive and just place that on the skin
rub that down then we're going to pull
the other back off put that on the skin
and then
put it down and again we confirm your
arrow is pointing toward the towards the
insertion side now that we've done that
we want to position the drainage bag
there's two things we want to remember
about this drainage bag and tubing first
thing is that this bag needs to be kept
below the patient's bladder at all times
never on the floor and never position it
on the part of the bed that's a movable
part because we don't want that catheter
to come out plus this tubing doesn't
need to have any kinks or Loops in it it
really needs to be a straight line and
we want to make sure we position the bag
so it does have a straight line so
gravity can easily drain that urine so
we will put this drainage bag at the
foot of the bed on a designated hanging
spot where it should go and we're going
to use this part this is called a sheet
clip we will connect this to the sheet
some spot to help keep the tubing in
that straight line and then once you get
that taken care of you can take the
stickers that came with your tray put
them where wherever your facility wants
you to put them once we have all of that
done we're going to finish cleaning up
our supplies make our patient
comfortable doff our gloves perform hand
hygiene and then we are going to
document